[Music]
so we begin in Libya where Al Jazeera
has been told that the foreign minister
has been dismissed for meeting with her
Israeli opposition number last week the
decision comes after a night of protests
across the capital Tripoli and several
other Libyan cities demonstrators burned
Israeli flags and demanded that najla
mangush be dismissed the Israeli foreign
minister and I Cohen described talks
with her in Italy last week as a
historic first step in establishing ties
But after those protests Libya's foreign
Ministry attempted to downplay the
meeting describing it as non-official
unauthorized discussions with Israeli
officials are illegal in Libya the
countries have had no formal relations
since the country gained independence
from Italy in 1951.
well in a minute I will speak to Harry
Fawcett who's in West Jerusalem but
first let's go to Malik trainer who's
standing by for us in Tripoli so Malik
what is the latest you have for us
wealth sources close to prime minister
Abdel Hameed has told us that nej
Libya's first female foreign minister
has been sacked as a result of this
meeting
they told us that the Prime Minister
wasn't aware of Nazareth mangush's
actions at her meeting uh from what the
Libyan foreign Ministries that are
informal meeting with eliko and the
Israeli foreign minister in Rome last
week but people here I mean were
extremely upset and are still extremely
upset last night we saw protesters
closing off main roads across all of
Western Libya we also saw a group of
protesters breaching the Libyan foreign
ministers gates for briefly last night
and due to that there was some serious
security concerns government sources
have told us that man Goose left Tripoli
last night and has arrived in Istanbul
although we haven't seen an official
statement yet from the foreign Ministry
just about 20 or 30 minutes ago we saw a
statement by the employees of the
foreign ministry here in Libya
condemning the actions of
mongoose saying that this isn't in sync
with the Libyan foreign policy so I mean
we're still going have to wait and see
as to as to what the what this
investigation there isn't an ongoing
investigation into this meeting so we're
going to have to wait for more
information that comes out
all right that's the view in Tripoli
thanks to Malik trainer there let's head
over to West Jerusalem now Harry Fawcett
is standing by so Harry Israel is saying
something quite different about the
circumstances of this meeting to Tripoli
entirely different yes we spoke to a
foreign Ministry official who said that
this was entirely a coordinated meeting
uh it was one that what that featured
direct talks and if you look at the
statement from the foreign Ministry from
Ellie Cohen on Sunday uh it talks about
the kind of content of these discussions
about agricultural cooperation water
technology restoring Jewish sites inside
Libya he called this a historic uh
meeting and a first step putting it in
the context of wider efforts of
normalization with other Arab Nations as
well so entirely a different narrative
also different when it comes to the
announcement itself the foreign Ministry
official saying that the idea of
announcing this meeting was also
coordinated although how far you could
really say it's coordinated is
questionable given the fact that this
official also said the timing of that
announcement had not been coordinated
and certainly the reaction from the
Libyan side suggests they were very much
caught unawares by this sudden
announcement on Sunday and that itself
has got a lot of criticism and backlash
from the Israeli opposition here the
lead of the opposition former foreign
minister himself former prime minister
yeah lapid saying that this was
amateurish that it puts in question
Israel's negotiations with other
countries who would be pretty uh
dismayed to see this kind of what he
called a leak and he also said that this
was a morning of National Disgrace for
the country when someone's life had been
endangered presumably a reference to the
Libyan foreign minister in reward just
for a headline on the day
Harry thanks for that uh Harry Fawcett
there in West Jerusalem
well Libya is divided between two rival
administrations there's a un recognized
government in Tripoli which is led by
Abdul Hamid al-baba where they Scandal
over the contacts with Israel is
happening there's also a rival
Administration in to Brook that's backed
by the United Arab Emirates it's also
had contacts with Israel but that has
not generated nearly as much controversy
the son of the Libyan warlord Khalifa
hafta visited Tel Aviv last year for
talks with senior Israelis
treatments
earlier I spoke with anasel gemati he's
the founder and director of sadak
Institute the first public policy think
tank in Libya he says news of The
Unofficial meeting is at odds with
what's been going on behind the scenes
it's obviously a major difference
between the official interactions or
even the discrete interactions that
you've mentioned there and the Divide
between the public perception I mean the
streets kind of made itself clear last
night
um with the protest in front of the
foreign Ministry protesters entering the
home of the Baba late last night and
it's this this kind of public dissonance
this big gap between what the Libyan
State officials and non-state officials
like have to say they do versus what
they actually do and I think that was
part of the reason why it was
um it struck such a nerve last night
because the way in which the news was
revealed the fact that it was revealed a
week later by Israel's foreign minister
and not by Libya's foreign minister
that's kind of led to this public outcry
and I think it was the frustration that
it really caused was what sparked so
many different protests last night what
is the official position of making
contact with Israel
Libya does not recognize as well
um and I think the official position has
been something that even when we go to
um leaks that have taken place over
meetings between Libyan officials and
William Burns the head of the CIA who
broached this conversation last year in
in meetings or this year rather in
meetings in January
um the position from the Baba quietly
was we can talk about normalization but
I'm worried about the public outcry and
I think he knows that Libya's official
position is one that is very closely
attached to the street but it's not just
that the street is against what it deems
to be Israeli interference I mean we've
seen this story kind of come to the
surface over the last several years
Khalifa after has extensive military
relationships was backed by Israel in
the last war on Tripoli in 2019. his son
was in in Tel Aviv for 19 minutes
according to hores uh on the uh in a
private jet where he requested military
support and diplomatic support in
exchange for being made the president of
Libya unusually he didn't actually throw
his hat into presidential election so
how he would have taken power was was
one of those curious kind of facts that
was always left to the final moment and
but I think again Libya's official
position is one thing but it's that it's
that dissonance with the streets that
has allowed for people to go out and say
look enough is enough
all right let's get a view from Israel
now Alan pinkas is a former Israeli
Diplomat and he served as an advisor to
the former Israeli Prime Minister Shimon
Peres joins us now from Tel Aviv uh Mr
Pinkus first up what's your view of this
uh meeting that's caused riots in Libya
well in Israel it's hailed as a first
step in establishing relations
well to be honest Nick
um it's hailed in Israel as a complete
um folk pie it's a it's a complete mess
up
as as a foreign minister who ran to tell
everyone about his conquests rather than
keep it discreetly and I have to tell
you you know if you look at the uh um at
the sequence of events
uh this is just like you know a a remake
of the uh old movie or the Jimmy Breslin
movie The Gang That Couldn't Shoot
Straight everything everything about
this was wrong
um and and you know it's uh it's really
a shame because if if there is some kind
of uh um if there are some kind of
understandings if there is a platform on
which anything some kind of dialogue
could be built it was ruined for the
foreseeable future with uh the Israeli
foreign minister blabbering about it and
reportedly at least the Libyan foreign
minister fleeing her country uh to
Turkey
they must be well you'd think there must
be some kind of cut some kind of
calculation behind this as far as the
foreign minister is concerned what would
you think in his mind that he would have
to gain or Israel would have to gain
from talking about the meeting in this
way
okay well you know it was uh uh totally
premature as I mentioned before but this
this this underscores uh Nick
a a larger concept which I happen to
think is deeply flawed
in in right wing Israeli thinking and
that is that you can ignore evade avoid
circumvent the Palestinian issue while
uh making gains or gaining traction or
even recognition throughout the Arab
world Libya the UAE Qatar
um Jordan and Egypt obviously and
conceivably even Saudi Arabia now that
that's all good and fine
uh but the thing is
um you know doing it and then uh
bragging about it prematurely uh and
undermines even even this concept which
again I think is flawed and and
deficient
in a sense
well yeah you know it could be a smoke
screen that you know that Israel is
making strides and and here we are
hypothetically negotiating indirectly
hypothetically negotiating with the
Saudis in a grand triangular a
tripartite deal with the U.S and
parallel to that uh you know uh doing
things with the libyans and okay let's
assume that is true let's assume forget
my uh I forget my reservations about the
concept or the conceptual framework here
let's assume this is good so why go out
and talk about this why the hell would
you excuse the expression why would you
go out and and brag about this
prematurely and basically uh on ruin and
undermine your own doing the thing is I
have also been visits from the
government in tall Brook haven't they so
they the Israeli officials have been
meeting two sides of the government in
Libya it makes you wonder what uh you
know what actual relationship there is
between behind the scenes that we don't
really know about or isn't public anyway
between Libya and Israel
well okay uh um I I doubt Nick that any
of the of our viewers right now recall
that in the 1990s in the mid 1990s in
the aftermath of the Oslo Accords
um of September 93 and then the
implementation 94 1995
there were initial contacts between
Israel and Libya still under Muammar
Gaddafi colony
um and that never matured into anything
and then a few years back as the
previous uh my immediate previous uh
guest told you
um there was some Israeli presence in
Israeli involvement in the ongoing uh
political strife and Civil War in in
Libya
um I doubt there's anything more than
that I doubt I I very much doubt there's
anything more than that at this point at
least it's odd isn't it because these
meetings that the Rival Administration
from tobrook have had have not generated
nearly as much controversy
well no because because uh you know for
the mere fact that uh the foreign
minister Ms man Goose had to uh flee
again reportedly uh had to flee uh
Tripoli and and go with her in a private
airplane uh to Turkey for fear her life
she by the way according to reports in
Israel in the last hour
uh she just uh said that uh the meeting
she had with the Israeli foreign
minister Mr Ellie Cohen was uh
coordinated that her prime minister knew
about this that in fact he he uh
coordinated the entire thing with the
Italian Prime Minister Ms Maloney
and uh the fact that it was prematurely
leaked by Israel embarrassed him and led
to the demonstrations and eventually uh
impaled her to flee uh Tripoli all
together I I don't know how accurate
that is I have no way of objectively
judging that information okay great to
get your perspective hello appreciate
that thanks very much Alan pink has for
me it's really diplomats
thank you